Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
En este momento, es probable que
estés sentado para ver el vídeo
y permanecer sentado unos minutos
para verlo está bien.
Pero cuanto más tiempo estés en
esa posición, más se perturbará tu cuerpo.
Este cuenta los minutos
hasta que te levantes de nuevo
y lo lleves a dar un paseo.
Puede que esto suene ridículo.
A nuestros cuerpos les encanta
sentarse, ¿verdad?
En realidad no.
Estar sentado por períodos breves
puede ayudar a recuperarnos del estrés
o recuperarnos del ejercicio.
Pero hoy, nuestro estilo de vida nos hace
sentarnos más de lo que nos movemos,
y el cuerpo simplemente no está pensado
para una existencia tan sedentaria.
De hecho, es justo todo lo contrario.
El cuerpo humano está diseñado
para moverse,
y esto se puede comprobar
por cómo está estructurado.
Tenemos más de 360 articulaciones
y unos 700 músculos esqueléticos
que nos permiten
el movimiento fácil y fluido.
La estructura física única del cuerpo
nos da la capacidad de ponernos de pie
en contra de la fuerza de la gravedad.
La sangre depende de nuestro movimiento
para circular correctamente.
Nuestras células nerviosas
se benefician del movimiento,
y nuestra piel es elástica,
así se amolda a nuestros movimientos.
Si cada centímetro del cuerpo está
preparado y a la espera de que te muevas,
¿qué sucede si no lo haces?
Empezaremos con el problema troncal,
literalmente.
Tu columna vertebral es
una estructura larga
compuesta de huesos y
discos de cartílago ubicados entre ellos.
Articulaciones, músculos y ligamentos
unidos a los huesos
mantienen todo junto.
Una forma común de sentarse es con
la espalda curvada con los hombros caídos,
una posición que presiona de
forma desigual la columna vertebral.
Con el tiempo, esto desgasta
los discos de la columna vertebral,
sobrecarga algunos ligamentos
y articulaciones,
y presiona los músculos
que se estiran
para acomodar la posición
curvada de la espalda.
Esta forma encorvada también reduce
la cavidad torácica al estar sentados
por lo que tus pulmones tienen menos
espacio para expandirse al respirar.
Eso es un problema, ya que limita
temporalmente la cantidad de oxígeno
que llena los pulmones y
que filtra la sangre.
Alrededor del esqueleto hay
músculos, nervios, arterias y venas
que forman las capas de tejido
blando del cuerpo.
El acto mismo de sentarse
aprieta, presiona y oprime,
y estos tejidos más delicados
realmente se llevan la peor parte.
¿Alguna vez tuviste entumecimiento e
hinchazón en las extremidades, sentado?
En las zonas más comprimidas,
los nervios, arterias y venas
pueden bloquearse,
limitando las señales nerviosas,
provocando sensación de adormecimiento,
y reduciendo el flujo de sangre en las
extremidades, haciendo que se hinchen.
Sentarse durante largos periodos también
hace desactivar la lipoproteína lipasa,
una enzima especial de las paredes
de los capilares sanguíneos
que descompone las grasas en la sangre,
así que cuando te sientas, no quemas
la grasa tan bien como moviéndote.
¿Qué efecto tiene todo esto en el cerebro?
La mayor parte del tiempo, quizá
te sientas para usar el cerebro,
pero, irónicamente, largos periodos
sentados en realidad hacen lo contrario.
Estar sentado reduce el flujo sanguíneo
y la cantidad de oxígeno que entra
en el torrente sanguíneo a los pulmones.
El cerebro requiere tanto de ellos
para permanecer alerta,
que tus niveles de concentración
muy probablemente bajan
conforme disminuye tu actividad cerebral.
Por desgracia, los efectos nocivos de
estar sentado no solo son a corto plazo.
Estudios recientes muestran que estar
sentado largos periodos
está vinculado a algunos tipos de cáncer
y a enfermedades del corazón
y puede contribuir a problemas
de diabetes, de riñón y de hígado.
De hecho, los investigadores
han calculado que, en todo el mundo,
la inactividad provoca aproximadamente
el 9 % de las muertes prematuras al año.
Eso supone más de 5 millones de personas.
Así que lo que parece ser
un hábito muy inofensivo,
en realidad, tiene el poder de
cambiar nuestra salud.
Pero por suerte, la solución a
esta amenaza es sencilla e intuitiva.
Cuando no tengas
más remedio que sentarte,
trata de cambiar la postura desgarbada
a una columna vertebral recta,
y si no tienes que estar
atado al asiento,
intenta moverte mucho más,
tal vez con una alarma para recordarte
que debes levantarte cada media hora.
Pero más importante, debes entender que
el cuerpo está creado para el movimiento,
no para el sedentarismo.
Así que, ya que el video
está a punto de terminar,
¿por qué no te levantas y te estiras?
Lleva a tu cuerpo a dar un paseo.
Te lo agradecerá después.